my next guest is crazy talented I mean
he's written so many songs you don't
even know he's written them he's sold
more than 20 million albums worldwide
and won three Grammys not too shabby
now he's back as a judge every Tuesday
evening on the hit NBC show my sister's
favorite show world of dance check it
out
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
alright y'all give it up for neo hey
what's up to you how you doing how are
you love
I'm hanging in there I think we're all
just it's a crazy here this year oh yeah
yeah but it's nice to see you again
and how have you actually been handling
the craziness all the lockdown cuz you
have kids with you yeah yeah I have four
beautiful children
four four very loud very energetic
children and they are thoroughly
enjoying all the downtime that they
really actually are and to be honest I
am too I am sooo I mean I mean you know
my part my condolences and my heart goes
out to anybody that they lost anybody to
co-lead the whole situation but as far
as the quarantine I rarely at home
anyway I travel a whole lot and this was
kind of an opportunity for me to to kind
of like reconnect with my kids you know
yeah I don't know if you I don't know
you know personally but you know before
quarantine you know me and my wife were
talking divorce but the quarantine kind
of allowed us the time to sit down and
really kind of you know lock back into
each other so like we did now there's
another horse but again it almost it
almost feels wrong to say that this
whole COBIT 19 quarantine thing was kind
of a blessing for me wow what a
beautiful thing that that it ended up
working out and and he took such a
negative situation it could have been a
really negative thing and made it a
positive with this pandemic and
everything going on Donna on another
positive though you just released a song
called you to love um what is it doing
what is we have what is the inspiration
is it your life so you to love featuring
Jeremiah by the way shout out to
Jeremiah the song basically is about I
mean the tagline is I own the one you
love I don't want nobody else so it's
basically just talking about you and
that one person and mind you we recorded
the song before the quarantine happen
but considering the quarantine is kind
of like the perfect quarantine Bay to
play the song you know the quarantine
Bay
yeah the couch with this plan and a
background is just a perfect scene it
makes perfect sense yeah
all right okay so you did something that
I like vald to never do again because
this is a very hard thing to do
I I'm saying at a few funerals in my
life and it's just the hardest scenario
ever if you know them or if you don't it
doesn't matter because you're seeing
other people's pain regardless and it's
just painful
you actually performed a george florence
funeral so he involved i believe that
the family reached out i got the
information something from my manager
but I believe they reached out an axe if
I would if I would sing and I mean of
course I said yeah so we got down there
I I tried to sit a little further back
you know because I didn't want I didn't
want the moment to be about me at all
you know I mean like I didn't want to do
this celebrity thing but the way they
saw me they pulled me up to it to a
close-up you know so I'm sitting there
and I get up on stage and second I got
up there I looking at anything his
daughter sitting right in front and and
and then all I can see in a moment was
my daughter
and it broke I broke I couldn't I
couldn't hardest thing to do yes I can
I couldn't get my words together or what
I wanted to say that came out wrong some
people misunderstood what I meant by
that but I know that's that's kind of
the breath thing twos I feel like I
heard there was a bit of blowback from
the funeral what did that hit you hard
like to where you were like wait that
was totally missed I got that was
twisted you know Italy
I want my initially it did cuz I'm I'll
be honest when I my manager called me
and told me about what was being said or
whatever and I instantly got upset like
like how could anybody really think that
I would stand up at this man's funeral
in front of this man's family and mean
anything negative or wrong about like
how could anybody make that mistake
right so I got upset and my response was
you know what intelligent people know
what I meant
yeah and anybody ignorant I ain't
worried about it but then but then my
manager had catch me he was like no
that's not what this is this moment is
really
really really important okay the least
you could do is take a few minutes to
make sure that people understand what it
is you're saying okay because ignorance
is division and we don't need division
right now right we need to do this right
that's it so take a second explain what
it is you meant not because you not
because anyone is owed an explanation
but because it's the right thing to do
in order for unity to be part of the
merrier not not division you know so I
took it upon myself I went into the
comics and I answer some people somebody
said he wasn't sacrificed he was
murdered
and I'm like okay well in the realm of a
lot of sacrifices they kind of involved
death
I mean it's unfortunate it's unfortunate
that his death was the spark that caused
this energy that is slowly but surely
created change for us but the truth of
the matter is this man's life was
sacrificed in order for this to happen
now I don't think that was the car that
was the reasoning behind it initially of
course cops killed him and it was meant
for it was wicked it was meant for
wicked but we then took something that
was meant for wicked and turned it into
a positive
ya know III agree um you're such a great
man um you're such a good dude it's so
cool I'm back with neo and you can see
him there yes on world advanced Tuesdays
on NBC seriously my sister is obsessed
with your show I've you sorry have you
been missing your friends at world of
dancing mr. Derek in jail um yeah man I
really truly have so so here's the thing
so the show is not live okay that's
that's no secret in one show is not live
we shot the last show the season finale
pretty much the day that this whole
corbin 19 madness began lucky day that
they started sending people home was the
was the day that we shot the final show
so we decided that for the first half of
the show we wanted to break it down like
like we wanted to make to make the
contestants earn that big beautiful
stage with the LED screen and all that
wanted to make them earn so the
qualifying round and the dual rounds are
all done in a warehouse now I think we
were a little bit ahead of our time I
think if you were a little bit of hour
ahead of our time because
hi hi hello oh my gosh you're adorable
[Laughter]
hi oh my gosh you beautiful smile -
hello that happens all the time - you're
good what I'm saying is I think we might
have been ahead of our time because the
qualifier rounds now the act will walk
in and it's literally just us and just
them there's no audience there's no no
light it's very quiet yeah yeah but like
before we even knew we were social
distancing before we knew that we needed
to but like okay so speaking of speaking
of dances and dance craze I remember I
mean I'm not a great dancer I'm like
that girl that can like dance remotely
okay like you know it's like but there's
but there's always been a dance craze
like I mean I just need a moonwalk or
dabbing or even the Roger Rabbit that
had its moment of like Oh everything has
its moment but so the name always seems
random you know of whatever dance craze
it is so when your friend Derek Hough
was here we asked him if he could create
some dances based on random phrases
I gave him so he's give me I'm gonna
call out random things to make up a
dance okay yeah no pressure don't suck
everyone's watching
okay the plunger
[Applause]
okay
a Gryffindor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
alright so we just showed the tape of
Derek obviously killing it in the video
he did really well so I I just feel like
you know you might you might be able to
one-up him one and also I feel like I'd
kind of like to participate this time
because I'm super competitive so I was
just are you are you challenging me
I challenge in you the next time that
you are in my studio and we can be
around each other I'll even be 62 apart
from you fine but I'm challenging you to
the same game my producer I don't know
the words
they'll call out a name and something
and we have to do it and I'm challenging
you and I think that I will whoop your
behind
that's what I'm saying you know what the
competitor and me is is is outraged
right now and I humbly challenge good I
like it I like it I'm gonna bring so
much heat but in the I mean I'm just
saying like when we can also go out and
go to parties I always like to ask
dancers because I'm not a dancer um what
is like a good cool chill moves if I'm
just like if I'm there at the party and
everyone starts dancing and I'm like I
don't want to be - like - like all this
sudden I'm busting out some choreography
I just want like a cool move that's more
than a sidestep what would you be more
than a sidestep okay King okay
I like I've mastered the art of dancing
and not sweating normally I'm just very
nice I've developed a dance technique
that you did allows you to still look
like you know what you're doing but not
sweat hey you said okay my two-step game
is very very cool maybe I need a better
to sub-game teach me that my feet yes
there are multiple two steps though say
papa bear by the way though there are
multiple two steps okay there's this
typical thing here yeah right but then
if you want to get fancy you can go here
over the switch up
all of this counts as dancing you can
totally just while holding your fabulous
yes I just need to work on the part that
you have mastered not sweating because I
are you a natural sweater on tour I look
at my makeup artist and apologize every
time I go out on the stage because I'm
like everything you did was really
pretty but in like seven minutes it's
gonna be gone completely not if I'm
holding a drink or like what do I do
with my hands cuz I feel like kind of
like so she does have a good night
that's what makes it that's what makes
it so cool so I'm holding my phone in
his hand but this will be the hand with
the drink in the other hand you can put
in your pocket I'm too cool exactly
I'm Way too cool to go out of my way and
sweat for everyone around no I'm nice
and dry yes
mellow and everyone's gonna look at me
and go wow look how cool that guy not
even dancing that's what happened I want
to be that person the bride a man she is
cool she's not even trying she's just
exuded excellence and awesomeness I love
you and I'm still happy for you and your
family - I'm glad that this pandemic
really helped gel and that said tonight
I think that's a beautiful thing when a
family can work it out so way to go on
that front - thank you so much for that
yes I'll be sure to catch neo Derek
Hough and JLo every Tuesday on world of
dance on NBC it's an amazing show
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going